so this is coffee infused cereal this is  not the actual act of pouring coffee  into your cereal i no  but i would i would try either honestly  that'd be an interesting move huh some  honey nut cheerios with a little bit of  cappuccino in there i don't know if that  would work though honey not cheerios  with coffee coffee honey  that sounds delicious i'm telling you  we've got another good food idea here  have you ever tried water with your  cereal thinking that  have you tried water with your cereal  well yeah but that was like  there was no milk left yes you don't  want to do that at all  you shouldn't because it's disgusting we  tried that  5 22. it was gross it is it is filthy  thank you diane we'll see you tomorrow  no more water with our cereal we've  declared that we'll stick with the  coffee